il vostro umore della
[Musica]
benvenuti solita stare oggi una
nuovissima storia a sé ma andremo in
eterno assieme a sanremo un viaggio
assieme in aereo però per caso mi dice
che succederà qualcosa di molto molto
strano perché questa è una storia di
robles sapete che i gestori di rho blast
succede sempre far fretta o di pauroso
le cose stranissime insomma nuova storia
assieme come sempre premiati i pop corn
mettetevi comodi
eccoci qua cambiato vestito è anche
vitale fine aveva cambiato maglietta e
ha messo una maglietta con la pizza ai
cuori sopra a cascata la vita sulla
maglietta ok allora dove dobbiamo andare
io mi imbarcarci venisse scritto e fatto
una totale ritardato e il biglietto
perché non mi fermino e guarda poi come
si sta chiamando ai giochi dobbiamo dare
qui allora un giorno potrebbe quindi
abbiamo ok va bene nel latte due figli
sono qui davanti a te
ma dietro perché ci si stende ndavi
ancora da bertani ma purtroppo non posso
muovermi da qui non ci credo vita ne sta
seduto a fianco l'altra ragazza se non
avete ancora stato mi piace la
58 masi se questo video raggiunge i 10
mila mi piace faremo anche la seconda
parte per di essere un'altra storia
dell'aereo che il plain story 2 queste
le storie 1 visto che mi chiedete se
primi nomi ei ma dove stiamo questa
energizzante in argomento numero di
biglietto questa la fila 5 io
allora io a a 14 ma quindi se volontario
o no del capitano ciao a tutti c'è il
pilota parla il tuo capitano quindi
siamo ben vero che il bordeaux sta
cercando il mio posto
al momento stiamo volando un'altitudine
di 33.000 pieni si scopre livello del
mare vediamo fuori dalla finestra se
cercate qualcosa ecco il mio posto sono
al fianco l'altra persona
sentiti libero di esplorare l'aereo wow
allora perché dobbiamo sederci non
possiamo aspettare da un lato tieni sono
non vada sedermi opposero perché
sappiamo che tra poco succederà qualcosa
come succede sempre nel lettore di rho
blacks e quindi meglio esplorare adesso
ho trovato la cucina ho trovato delle
forbici come i trovate la sua scherzando
ora questa porta è aperta ora vi prego
di tornare al vostro posto mentre stiamo
per attraversare una delle testate
imponenza morirò 14
ecco la turbolenza ios tosto storico
nato monitorerà dietro che è accaduto a
prato la tua vita si un pochettino sì
allora mi raccomando stai attento perché
qua se muori poi bisogna reinserito
della carovana bisogna rendere spendere
uno spuntino per tutti ecco vitale non
vedeva l'ora bufano posto del mio fianco
terno questo lo sai perché perché
all'inizio se esiste non ti sei seduto
affianco a me e quindi non ci hanno
assegnato il posto vicino perché per te
io me ne vado ciao guarda panino giusto
prezzo
io non me bisogna stiamo molto bene sta
iniziando la storia aspetta aspetta che
questo panino abbiano maionese sono
allergico alla maionese
poverino non dove e mangiarlo o no
veloce in fretta dobbiamo trovare il
bagaglio per la medicina guardare le
deposito bagagli sopra di voi presto ci
mettiamo certo poteva premio per tutti
così qui non c'è chi non c'è non ce la
cerchiamo di questa parte col hanno
trovato forza dai bei premi lo prendi lo
ho trovato da torno che qualcuno l'ha
trovata qua perfetto quello era vicino
come sempre le tasse
translate
pomeriggio
vi forniamo che abbiamo raggiunto
un'altitudine di dare un bomber da un
buon momento per sedersi a fare un
pisolino godersi il viaggio va bene che
resti a dormire
no vedi non stiamo mica dormendo rilassa
hanno passato le molla luce buonanotte
passeggeri ricca reti di allungare le
gambe abbiamo ancora qualche ora da
perte ok perdere non problema perdere
questo allungamento gambe completato
così
che sta succedendo lunga dire che stai
parlato lei io mi chiedo sembra che
abbiamo perso energia
resisti mentre cerchiamo di sistemarla
io credo ma non hanno saputo apposta
guardate come piace quando parlava alla
resa qual è la destra questa è sito che
sono tutti noi
massimo mostra signore dell'aereo tutto
lo stai vedendo del finestrino guarda tu
non lo farà a sopravvivere molto bene
sono quelle vivendi sono serpente
davvero tutto
solo uno di euro si si non farti
prendere dei serpenti
hanno fatto dei serpenti entrare nella
ero
io sto saltando quadra i sedili
ma come questo si aspettano tanto
c'è un bagno aperto dove presto saremo
sicuri dove ho visto che entrava
qualcuno e quello verde di qua di qua di
qua c'era c'era non c'è più dove non c'è
perderete tutti conosciuti video stanno
inseguendo queste persone 10 secondi per
entrare un bar gay e questo è deformato
fregati quello che la porterò verde non
con la luce verde per un pelo picchiano
stabile giro è stato spaventoso
dovremo discutere di cosa ti queste
diavolo sta succedendo sì direi che non
è normale che ci siano dei serpenti
nell'aereo è un mostro nell'ala
dell'aereo rango facciamo dobbiamo
rimanere fermi 4 e ora che succede siamo
sopravvissuti in pochi 25
il potere è tornato indietro si potrebbe
forse vuol dire il 2 a luciana l'energia
per tutti se ne sono andati la creatura
sull'altra la è sparita krypi chi vuol
dire spavento molto in inglese ecco il
pilota che dice la vostra adesione
passeggeri o buone notizie cattive
notizie cominciamo con le buone la buona
notizia è tornata l'energia
nell'aereo e quella cattiva la cattiva
notizia è che stiamo perdendo spesa
affatto per una sommità me l'hanno
proposto o creati siti ha supposto che
ammettere le vostre con lo stage lo
prendi neo che una rapida ed a questo o
no no no no no no non ci sono dove sono
le maschere aiuto non si sono morto dove
saranno le maschere però sono rinato
non è giusto che nuovo non sono apparse
le banche che succede o no non mi dire
ok o mio dio che cosa addosso cos'è
questo che cos'è sembra una bomba casa
ma che fa successo
debbo prendetevela subito allora vediamo
bene a tutti calmati troviamo qualcosa
di affilato per tagliare i cavi potremmo
essere in grado di salvare la vita
stories dai trovate qualcosa per
salvarli ho trovato un paio di forbici
ma io posso muovermi
di laura col quale cavo dovrei tagliare
taglierò il cavo rosso spero di non
esplodere io me lo sono fatto
spendere altri robot maestra ma chi ha
deciso italiani cava rozza fortuna non
sono stato io non abbiamo mai sentito
parlare l'equipaggio da un po
dovremo cercare e controllare
soprattutto che è vero non si sente più
il pilota o le hostess sembra che siamo
da soli chi sta guidando l'aereo forse
in auto pilot proviamo traguardo
abbinano non si apre qua capitano di
milano e ho trovati dove senti ma perché
succede di tutto il pescato abbiamo
all'attivo il capitano io sono peso una
borsa attesi paletto sta succedendo
qualcosa dentro il capitano potrebbe
essere nei guai pesto entriamo questa
porta ha bisogno di un codice se lo
troviamo potremmo essere in grado di
aprirla e dove sarà il codice che lo
dice codice in bottiglia codicistiche 41
codice bravo breve prima e ora speriamo
che il capitano sia ancora in vita
vedremo mai
non è capitato ho
fatto io sono già arrivato alla fine
dell'aereo
vidal è scampato fatto tu pagherà per
quello che fai
capiamo perché hai fatto è aperta la
porta credi di essere qui per incidente
c'è per caso ma non lo sei
ci ho portato qui tutti voi questo non è
possibile dico io no e quindi chi è ora
è ora di morire no io mi dà stato qua
dietro è quella ragazza rimasta ferma
davanti al mostro ci vediamo nell'aldilà
ok è sparito guarda quindi possiamo
andare adesso dal capitano non lo so se
si può entrare là dentro che mi pare un
capitano rientriamo vediamo se possiamo
fare qualcosa
wow
pericolo dice dobbiamo fare qualcosa il
capitano al primo differenti dobbiamo
vedere lei io prima che si schianti non
c'è problema sta accadendo e adesso
possiamo premere il bottone faremo noi
dobbiamo pensare si possono tra mai
fatto a breve aspetta aspetta che chiamo
tutti i bottoni
dobbiamo trovare il pilota automatico
dai primi tutti i bottoni e lo sto
provando poi lo troveremo clicca su
tutto e trova il pulsante prima di
morire
eccolo ho trovato è trovato c'è un vero
peccato non funziona non ha bisogni
primari tutti ho
capito ho capito
bene o male esistono altre due persone
con noi brave trovato il bottone
veramente non mi sono accorto della
francia e l'abbiamo fatta abbiamo
salvato da ieri e oggi ancora pericolo è
stato un volo molto pazzo dei voglio
solo essere a casa di chi come facciamo
ad atterrare adesso sembra che stiamo
nello spazio tutto mio fuori dai patiti
atterrare ora tutto ciò che dobbiamo
fare è trovare un telefono di emergenza
così possiamo chiamare aiuto ok sbriga
così
come non si è forse alla fine dell'aereo
dove sciamano le hostess io controllo
qui diamoci prima che scada il pilota
automatico
pronto abbiamo bisogno di aiuto il
nostro capitano privo di sensi non ti
preoccupare il porteremo a casa e di un
attimo va tutto bene
sì stiamo bene per ora la modalità
pilota automatico e attiva abbiamo
rintracciato la tua posizione
smentiamo cadore mondo il controllo
speriamo che non sia una trappola anche
fatta ho paura che lo sia c'è un ultimo
compito che ho per te
qualcuno deve tenere l'aereo in
carreggiata ci penso ai on the cyborgs
larghissimo trovate qualcuno che sia sul
sedile dal copilota parte dai sbrigati
non possono le hostess che hanno perso
coscienza poverine dai vita sbrigati
assistono cercando di andare a casa che
lo rende la ragazza perché sia brava ok
gente o questo è lo sta nel senso è
sotto controllo a lui sta ballando che
succede ogni giorno del vostro
bio bio non si può scappare
no no è tornato cosa dobbiamo fare per i
pulsanti nuovamente
wide web e il tuo destino è già stato
scritto da chi l'ultima possibilità in
lei la ragazza che sta parlando di
attore queste aeree noi governeremo gli
inferi per l'eternità io non sto facendo
sto salvando questo aereo mani siete
così io sto premendo il bottone
noi umani siete così deboli questo non è
il ultimi mesi
quindi lui ha cercato di convincere la
ragazza a schiantare l'aereo ha detto di
no meno male se n'è andato ok grazie per
averci dato schietta rito si aspetta ha
detto che non era l'ultima volta che lo
vediamo che lo vedrai cosa intendeva che
tornerà presto chi s'è presa
torniamo a casa cristo per mobilitare
bellissimo
non ci credo ci sono le abbiamo vinto il
premio sei sopravvissuto
esatto seriate morti soprattutto io
perché mi avete fatto
morti tre volte è vero è stato
mi piace
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite
buona visione ciao